we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day many of you do call very
very late late at night early in the
morning here is a caller commenting on
those USA chants that have become very
common at trump presidential campaign
style rallies hey David I just wanted to
say I hate the USA chant more than any
chance I may be well maybe like you know
Jews will not replace this is worse but
the USA chant is pretty bad and okay I
guess that's it they didn't have
anything else to say listen I don't have
a problem with people chanting things at
rallies I think that there are many
worse chants than USA USA like for
example kill the Jew would be like like
a worse chant I think than USA but I
understand what the caller is saying
which is that in the context of these
Trump rallies in the context of those
rallies that contain endless lies and
distortions and all sort of nonsense I
understand why the entire concept of
just USA USA USA the meaning it takes on
is sort of a wild angry crowd cheering
for things that they don't even really
fully understand but that it includes
stuff that's really bad for a lot of the
people that are in our country and it's
sort of an exclusionary chant in a lot
of ways
well it doesn't bother me because it can
be perceived as nationalistic so much it
just bothers me because I find it
obnoxious it's obnoxious and also a lot
of the stuff Trump is talking about at
the rallies isn't good for a USA it
might be good for the very rich it might
be good for you you know in some cases
banks or whoever's regulations are being
reduced but it's not actually good for
the USA and the people there aren't even
informed enough to realize that did you
hear the pro England chance at the World
Cup
those were obnoxious what were those
were singing songs the national anthem
they had like a little horn they were
playing yeah wouldn't recommend it you
didn't like that did not like that okay
that doesn't really know about soccer
culture though you admit that yeah I
mean I pretend to every four years when
the help comes around but I do not know
all right well maybe the US will make it
next time
and people here will have something to
cheer for other than you they'll have an
opportunity to say USA USA in a way
that's not implicitly supporting the
harebrained and ridiculous policies of
President Donald Trump we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today the
bonus show is world-famous it's
accessible to members and patrons number
1 on the bonus show we will talk about
how a vandal demolished Donald Trump's
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
called cops to say see you soon and was
ultimately bailed out by the last person
to damage Donald Trump's star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
very unusual story the attorney for
Brock Turner argues that Turner's sexual
assault conviction should be overturned
and we will also also talk about Betsy
DeVos proposing rules that would cut
student loan relief by an estimated
thirteen billion dollars because these
kids don't need to have help with their
student loans forget about the fact that
wages are stagnant for 40 years and that
college costs continue to go up they
need to pull themselves up by the
bootstraps from the boots they can't
even afford and just write themselves
economically that and more on today's
bonus show get access to ways become a
member at WWN pakman.com if you want to
save 40% you can do it with the coupon
code vote soon 18 second way to get
access to the world-famous bonus show is
to become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show for at least 5 bucks a
month five bucks five dollars and one
cent $500 as long as it's at least 5 you
will get instant access to the bonus
show we will speak to you then